I made this iconic 90s Barbie cake that
is perfect for Barbie core summer
because I cannot wait to see Margot
Robbie's sleigh as the world's favorite
plastic girly Pop I remember seeing
these cakes on display at Costco when I
was a kid so I was so excited to learn
that you can easily buy a cake mold to
make your own if you want to keep it
super simple boxed cake batter really
allows you to just focus on the
Aesthetics the trick with this cake is
to cut a Barbie shaped hole in the top
two layers before you start decorating
the cake serves as Barbie's skirt so we
went ham decorating with enough pink
frosting for several Barbie multiverses
but if you really want to wow your
friends you can hide a concoction of
sprinkles inside for a nice little
surprise later and top it off with
Barbie to display to the world just
pretend you don't know that she is in
fact legless inside and finish off with
a ridiculous amount of edible glitter
I'm so excited to see Barbie and Ken in
all their fabulousness on the big screen
and this cake is a perfect way to
celebrate with a little bit of nostalgia